Now that we have an equation for that almost geostationary orbit.
Let's look at what the computer simulation does to that, so we start at this point, wait for 24 hours,
precisely 24 hours, and look at what's going to happen.
Most probably, we're not going to reach that same precise location but end up
in a slightly different location, and the objective of this quiz is to compute
the distance between the initial position and the position after precisely 24 hours
to learn about the error of our method.
We've got tons of stuff predefined ready for you to use.
Your job is to insert the Euler forward method right at this point.
Your job is not to return the positions and the velocities, your job is to return just a single number,
namely the error--the distance between the initial position and the final position--
and up front of course compute the step size.
Given the number of steps, make sure that you actually are taking, for instance, 200 steps
after that initial position or 500 or 1000 and so on.